the bleak show about horrible people
that has somehow become a fun pop
culture meme gets the honest trailers
treatment from screen junkies I'm
excited to see this how do you make
jokes about something that is confused
with every other sentence
in this series just one of Yahoo's
dr. microphone used to sell exotic
animal sanctuary and also probably for
the
that took the shot from true cry - holy
Sh
no way that's true crying that was smart
enough compelling you never go hold yo
exotic and walks the beginning really of
the biggest thing to happen to Tigers
since zoo books because a faculty to
play Joe students are already on their
way and you just know it's gonna be Raja
president mother
story jokes crack team of employees
watching what people did just get that
appraiser that was put so Craigslist was
a hot-headed from now kept me really
know anything about this I worked as a
mo section when I got the job offer to
work for Joe's like what's the job he
said campaign manager Vito
made a pact thing with that we shoot
each other going broke names not this
color sir not mine Joe maxed out all the
credit cards they had Joe against the
ropes because he was broke he makes a
staff $150 a week I don't use Oh
Tigers who've aged out of the play time
events in a gas chamber
[Laughter]
[Music]
and you lose your money
[Music]
[Music]
that was really interesting honest just
noticing how they didn't really need
jokes at all there was a lot of the time
they would kind of say something in the
first parts that were making fun of it
but a lot of time it was just a couple
lines explaining it and then all the
humor came from just playing a whole
bunch of footage it literally I want to
see the commentary on this one they
couldn't have had to have done much to
embellish I mean I'm not going to say
there were no jokes or definitely jokes
I was just a little bit like oh wow the
editors just need to rely on the visuals
you know oh yeah because you've got
everybody who are already dressed like
the most insane characters in these semi
exotic like they look like set
decorations from a movie there shouldn't
exist you've got all these like wild
looking people who are all eccentric and
specific and character like and it
totally breaks reality
I gotta admit though I did start going
to a dark place watching this that's
kind of my weird thing with tiger King
is that I've had arrived I've noticed
how yeah like it's become this huge pop
culture meme and it's wildly
entertaining undoubtedly it was this
addicting chaotic mess just to watch
it's like a car crash but at the same
time I've kind of feel like the way it
sort of swept pop culture has been like
it's like it's fun but I've never like
it's a really deep dive in here I was
noticing my emotions were dipping when
we were doing their you know their title
credits that are starring credits just
kind of getting lost in the bleakness of
the footage she's reminding me of like
oh yeah I forgot how heroine oh yeah
break it down into little categories and
you compartmentalize them you can kind
of see the stuff that's behind all the
veneers and all of the performance that
everyone in the show is putting on that
being said when they pointed out Carol
Baskins laughs gain earshot the neighbor
gun I picked up the dog really enjoyed
that because she would laugh at
everything and it only just made at
least he has an audience viewer further
believe that she probably did the
horrible thing she did because she
sometimes she tell a story of this is
how ridiculous the accusation is huh and
then under time she'd just be telling a
story
it was clearly she was telling a
truthful story or at least her version
of the truth and it started to be
horrible things did you start cracking
up it seemed like uncomfortable laughter
like um so I'm laughing because I'm
uncomfortable to share this it seemed
like laughter that she genuinely thought
was kind of funny or ironic okay we're
like some sort of application to make
her come across that much more sort of
chipper and carefree or something
because there's something wrong there
yeah watching this back there is so much
that is amusing and fun but the more
Tiger King is sat in my mind it's like
it's so engrossing when you're just
learning the story but the more distance
I get from it and while I do still get a
kick out of syringes
just the ugliness is is all that is
rising to the surface now I thought that
some of their like little film
references were really funny here about
like comparing it to waiting for Guffman
because it really is like a code
brothers meets a Christopher Guest movie
in that way and as an honest trailer
borrowing from film stuff I thought that
was really astute but yeah just watching
all this I was like this is just a great
way to categorize how much bad behavior
and abuses on displaying the show and
their point about the polygamist element
to it saying I think we all flash to
who's who's the guy with all the woman
canceled we all flash to da canto but
Joe exotic did the same thing instead of
jet low he used these tires as a weird
enticement to expand the
the children burped water I'm sure that
this Scarface guy has like a way bigger
history that they didn't dive into here
but I was like how are you the one dude
who just like has a wife yeah are you
the most normal seeming guy on all these
I remember when Shaq pop-up in this
documentary oh no Jack what have you
done to Beyonce Beyonce that one heard I
mean that I could imagine was probably
more celebrities than just the ones that
we know about whose photos are surfacing
online it's don't need to try to cancel
them or attack them we don't need we
need their opinion on it you know it's
like this is the thing a lot of people
were doing and then this is the expose
of these petting zoos which I feel like
for a long time we've probably assumed
that there's some shady things in terms
of breeding we would feel that way about
like regular zoos San Diego LA New York
zoos but I've seen some people online
like trying to bring them down for
attending but come on I don't think we
need to go that far yeah and I feel like
this is part of the time where we'll
learn to not go do that and you they go
do that now that's not a great place to
go host Tiger King lager like a trump
jr. said know how cheap it was so entire
case I wouldn't when you have people who
are lost enough down a hole of vanity
and materialism and megalomania like
yeah that becomes the first thought in
your mind is I could I should have got a
tiger and I would have gotten new
trouble for doing it and one thing that
I thought they did a nice job of
pinpointing here that I think will
continue if Tiger king keeps its status
is the stuff like Joe exotics apparent
racism which seems like a questionable
move on a documentary side of things
because if there are flaws to this
person's character that are like
wholesale left out like I don't know the
extent but at least they brought it up
here and now I'm wondering would we all
have responded really differently to do
exotic if there was more of that side of
his personality in the doc you know and
it really raises a lot of interesting
questions I think this whole ordeal
about these people and how we respond to
them when they're delivered to us in
this kind of package
you know I mean the thing is I wonder
it's like do they not get that on camera
be surprised they didn't get it on
camera after many countless things to
exotic was willing to say especially
with the threats like I they point out
in the songs trailer like threats of
violence but there's other like strange
reports surfacing of there's like some
weird taxidermy reports I surf is seeing
that a could possibly involves sexual
activity with the animals and then like
because they were doing that called me
sexy tiger they're doing that joke about
like the line between animal over an
animal lover and then I was thinking
about the reports I recently heard of
this is really disturbing to look back
at this footage now that I have those
reports fresh in my head yeah well kind
of reports I can imagine especially for
the type of operation this is for how
much shadiness is out there and for how
many people churn in and out of these
organizations I can only imagine that
we're going to be in for a barrage of
weird tales yeah and there's a new
episode out now or Joel McHale is
interviewing I think majority of them I
haven't seen that yet everybody checks
alright guys well Tiger King I don't
know there was all these people these
celebrities opting to play these guys so
I'll throw it to you who do you think
should play Joe exotic in the
live-action biopic I'm thinking Andy
Dick I mean Andy Dick's gotta get a role
in there I'm thinking Joe exotics should
be played by Walton Goggins over there
you go he's a good pick just cast him in
that and the Macmillan's movie and there
you go have a Goggins reality Cinematic
Universe we should do a fan casting
video one day of dr. King yeah Warren on
the line guys subscribe to honest roasts
if you haven't done so already he can
subscribe to the real rejects click
tower notification Bell I need to go eat
something
hey before we wrap this video up hey
Tyler Hague and l-b I thought I'd be fun
for this month in particular to do some
fanfiction of our patronage X what if
they met each other's LB beautiful woman
from Arkansas who definitely had
scene Tiger King and Tyler Haig probably
work at one of these petting zoos one
day probably play one of these people
this John keeps playing the woman I'll
play Alby you play Tyler head good
interior lobby afternoon the real
rejects are gearing up for a
meet-and-greet
Tyler hang a handsome man with the
presents that conveys pure innocence
waits in line playing on his iPhone
standing in front of lb a beautiful
southern belle how long you been
watching the real rejects for oh you
know for years toddler goes back to his
phone my name is Elle by the way Albay
oh you know my name is Tyler Tyler Hague
wait a minute the Tyler Hague the man
who gave Greg a PlayStation 4 for his
birthday oh you know that's me wow
really is an honor to meet you Greg is
constantly praising you have you gotten
Greg any gift that big no I haven't I'm
too busy working on journalism you
should do an article on how you're not
as big of a supporter of the real rich
exes oh yeah well I'm one of the female
fans
oh so you're waiting to do something
special to chocolate isn't he dreamy
Greg's always been my favorite you talk
funny where are you from I'm from
Arkansas yourself
we're Scott with stance what do you do
for fun I usually have 5 monitors going
at once while I play games watch the
real rejects have two movies playing and
one TV show what do you do for fun i
watch and recommend BTS videos for John
to react to when you meet John what are
you gonna do I have some photos house
waiting a long time to give him why
don't you just message him on Instagram
and send the pics like how I've done for
Greg John probably gets so many pictures
from the female fans I didn't want to
get lost in the pop it sounds like your
section of the shout out is more about
Greg's jealousy towards John that it is
about you what does the B stand for in
your name beautiful no it doesn't
honestly after three years I never told
Greg so he couldn't include it is your
name el short first
thing I don't know you never told Greg
huh yeah and he just assumes I'm super
into John wait are you really a degree
yeah it's great script chica Creed
reality however he wants yeah John can
go straight to hell
Tyler and he'll be then passionately
make out rubbing printed out photos of
Greg all over their face yeah
you